good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here and you know up a professor
cloud Barrett who is my collaborator on
this project Clark and I we are going to
talk about how to achieve dramatic
improvements in our validation and debug
for system-on-chips and the scheme that
we will be using is called QED and
symbolic QED now it's a loaded term QED
really stands for quick error detection
that's what I'm going to talk about but
we have another motive which is once you
know you use this QED technique to
validate your chips you would say well
you know this chip works end of proof
QED right so uh so of course you know
I'm here up I am presenting the work but
all this work has been done by the
students on the collaborators so they
deserve the credit you know we are just
here to present their work so we know
that there is an explosive growth in our
dependency on electronic systems and I
was at a meeting of the National Academy
up you know like last year and they were
talking about this you know societal a
scale problems right you know water
world hunger education and all that and
everybody said that the only way to
solve that problems is to information
technology right and that's something
that I felt very proud of because I work
in that space but guess what when you
are going to plant electronics inside
your body to monitor and actuate and do
all sorts of things you don't want that
thing to just crash right which means
that if you really have to achieve that
we must ensure robust operation right
now if you look at chips today on the
other hand there is a staggering
complexity of integrated circuits it's
no longer just you know talking about
some processors and that's it this is an
SOC or a system-on-a-chip and you see
that is it has a whole bunch of stuff it
has a bunch of processors it has
accelerators like GPUs and DSPs and so
on it has mixed signal components and it
has a whole bunch of other components
that Intel if you were from Intel you
would call it the uncor
which means everything that's outside
the core and that would be like power
management memory controllers network
controllers you name it so that's the
beast that you know we must make sure
that it works right and guess what
what's really going on in industry is
that you can have all sorts of new
architectural features that you can
think about right if you are an
architect you can have all sorts of new
designs that you can think about to
solve the energy efficiency problem to
improve performance and so on and so
forth the only trouble is that you won't
be able to verify that whether your
techniques actually work and as a result
it won't see the light of the day so
here is a quote from my friend Ian young
he's a senior fellow at Intel and he
said that new architectural features are
limited by validation and you see
thought this was bad look at this chart
so this is a very simplified carton a
picture of you know up how chips are
built so you do a design and while you
design you write the Verilog or
something and then you do what is called
pre silicon verification to just make
sure that this design doesn't have bugs
there you go no we don't want to install
ok and then up you send that chips to be
built by the foundry and oh my goodness
forget was fun sorry good ok so the
chips are built by the foundry and the
chips come back from the foundry you
know you do a live in a post silicon
validation and bring up and then you
know you have high volume of chips that
you know go out to the customers now
guess what this is a chart from Intel
and I often joke that how do you tell
that a charges from Intel then there are
no numbers on you know on any of the
axis right but if you look at the number
of bugs that escaped during design and
show up during pre silicon during post
silicon validation that's shooting up
and that me of this curve that you see
that was sort of around the time that
you know multi-core chips were
introduced so you can see the massive
complexity over here so clearly the pre
silicon verification that we do today is
inadequate and if you thought that was
bad I think things are going to get much
worse and that's because the chips and
systems that we build today they are
facing some major obstacles many walls
simultaneously all of you know about the
power wall right that's why you cannot
go to frys electronics and buy a 10
gigahertz microprocessor now why is that
important you know in this context of
complexity this is a reason the reason
that you cannot go and buy a 10
gigahertz microprocessor that has to do
with fundamental physics which is called
the Dennard scaling of you know
transistors but now when the transistors
are not getting better from an energy
efficiency standpoint but my mom wants a
better computer a better cell phone
which means that the world needs high
performance systems the only way to get
performance and by performance I just
don't mean speed I mean energy
efficiency and all that the only way to
achieve performance when the technology
is not getting better is by embracing a
lot of complexity and that's exactly
what's happening today and that's why
you are seeing up these accelerators
this multiple cores you know power
management thermal management and you
name it and as a result of this massive
complexity this verification and the
problem of bugs gets very significantly
difficult okay so what do we do about it
well you know what does the industry do
today well you know so when these chips
you got back from the foundry what would
you do well you know you plug into the
system and I literally no of companies
that play games on these systems because
games sometimes tend to expose bugs that
you would not otherwise find right and
if you are lucky you are going to see
the blue screen of death if you are not
not not lucky your customers are going
to see that and just consider yourselves
you know sitting in front of that blue
screen staring at it and trying to find
out that which one of the billions of
transistor
that are there inside that chip just
cause a little error in which ones of
the trillions or quadrillions of cycles
that thing was running so that you can
actually go and tell you know which part
of the chip is not working and you know
that's called localization and then you
have to root cause and fix your problem
and it keeps going on and on and if you
look at the numbers from industry if you
find that it takes weeks or months of
manual work / bug right so that's crazy
so why is that so the reason is that the
existing techniques are completely
ad-hoc now for those of you that are
wondering you know what this is this
this picture was shared by my friend you
know Jason Stinson who used to be at
Intel and used to do a lot of this
validation stuff needs to be a very
senior guy and you know but essentially
what's going on this is a very high-end
validation system what's happening is
that you actually cannot see the chip
which is sort of sitting somewhere over
here right you cannot see it now who can
tell me what these windows are you can
see those windows you know over there in
the picture first take action behind
yeah there's a logic analyzers basically
right and all these things that you are
seeing these are actually cables that
are connecting the the pins of the chip
into this logic analyzers with the hope
that somebody will you know like collect
all this information and be able to
figure out what the heck is going wrong
you know with that chip right you know
what caused that blue screen so
essentially really this is not a
scalable way of doing things and as a
result are the post silicon costs are
rising faster than the design costs yes
in a system of this sort this complexity
that much hardware and so forth this has
been tested at real time or is it
necessary to slow down the main
processor clock because of the delays to
the logic analyzers in bed
the answer is all of the above right
because first they would run real time
but then when they will find that up
that there would be there would be a
problem for example there is a hang i
will show you some you know real
examples very soon then what do you do
you know that's when you try to slow
down you try to decon figure and all
that but guess what a lot of these bugs
are what software guys would call
Heisenberg's because once you have
slowed something down or Deacon figured
something the bug is gone right so it's
a it's a it's a it's a nightmare you
know to deal with I will show some
actual examples of that this seems to be
an equal number of ethernet cables going
somewhere okay and if you thought that
was a problem at the chip level and the
chip guys have to deal with it here is
actually a plot from Cisco so what does
Cisco do so they either build their own
Essex or they buy asics from other
vendors and they be large systems right
and when their customers complain that
some system is not working well the
first thing they have to do is to find
out with chip is not working right
before they can go and do anything else
and you don't have to really read these
histograms bottom line what it is saying
is that up to sixty percent of the
situation's they end up identifying the
incorrect chip to be the bad chip forget
about trying to even figure out what in
the world is going wrong so problem this
problem gets even magnified at the
system level okay so how do we do about
it so you know so we sort of have to
solve this problem so I always tell my
students I say that you know like so
this problem looks like an impossible
problem and why would you know somebody
in academia try to solve an impossible
problem some sounds like an industrial
problem and so on so I always tell my
students that when there is a problem
which looks impossible that means that
we really do not understand what the
problem is right so we have to really
understand what is the real problem here
and we have figured out what the real
problem is and i believe and i have
enough evidence by now to prove to you
that the real problem is the following
what is really going on is that so when
you play that game
run the test or whatever that is so what
is a bug a bug is a goblin sitting
inside the chip right and at some point
in time the Goblin triggers so when the
bug is triggered what does it do well
some flip-flops somewhere inside the
design by the way designs have millions
of flip-flops okay so some flip-flops
somewhere inside the design captured a
zero instead of a one or a one instead
of a zero right if I supposed to contain
zero now it contains a one now you do
not know that that one became was zero
or zero became a one right but up when
the crash happened that's when you
figure out that there was some kind of
an incorrect operation that was going on
inside the tube that's why that crash
happened not some hang happen or
something right so what the Goblin
really did was at that real error
occurred somewhere over here right but
you know about it over here now if that
time difference was very short let us
see it was only ten clock cycles then
you know you could do something right
you know you might be able to go and
figure out that what was going wrong but
in real life what happens is this time
difference is billions of clock cycles
billions with Abby now 1 billion clock
cycle by the way is one second right so
on real-world time it's very short but
it's billions of clock cycles and it's
impossible to make a system go back
billions of clock cycles to sort of
figure out what in the world is going
wrong and that's why you have this whole
validation and debugging nightmare okay
so what I'm going to show in the in the
first part of this presentation is I'm
going to show you a technique called QED
and hear the results that I am going to
show that QED is going to find the bugs
billion times quicker billion with a B
which means that if that error detection
latency that I was talking about if that
was 10 billion cycles before now it will
be 10 cycles and i will show you actual
hardware data to improve that also what
i will show you is that since i find the
errors much quicker billions in a
billion x quicker so the errors will
have much fewer chances to get masked
and as a result i will be finding more
bugs
so as a result my coverage will go up
and since I find this errors a billion
times quicker whatever takes weeks or
months of manual work I can actually
accomplish that overnight automatically
which means that nobody you know has to
really do anything manually the designer
can at the end of the workday can go
home and click a button and next morning
when the designer comes back you know
the system will be ready to tell you
know what kinds of bars are there in the
system and how to fix those bugs and so
on and so forth and it's broadly
applicable to in a processor cores uncle
components form where in a logic bugs
electric electrical bugs you name it
later in this presentation a professor
Clark Barrett is actually going to show
you a symbolic version of this approach
called symbolic QED and by doing that
and I'm stealing his thunder so that you
should be in this room he can show you
that he can actually run formal
verification formal okay formal
verification on a billion transistors
SOC okay automatically and as a result
this approach is not only just useful
for post cilic and validation but it can
find a huge chunk of bugs during pre
silicon verification as well so that's
what he is going to show I was very
careful and the reason I was very
carefully sigh I'm actually going to
show you some data on software too so we
believe that this approach should be
applicable to software but I don't have
extensive data for you to prove to you
that you know like the effectiveness of
this technique for soft I am very
careful about what I claim you know so
that's why I did not write software but
you will see that in C programs we were
able to find bugs using this approach in
principle I have proved that you can do
it but I have not spent an awful lot of
time to really nail that now okay so uh
so let's let second the simplest example
of a bug why would the error detection
latencies be so long so let's take a
multi-core chip okay and let's say that
you know they're a bunch of course and
so on and so forth and people will
really take
you that oh you know I got a bug what is
your bug or the system deadlox after a
while that's a bug but the deadlock is
not really a bug right remember the bug
is a goblin sitting inside the chip at
some point in time it changes as one to
a zero or a 0 to a 1 right so what's
really happening is the following for
this this is the simplest bug that you
can think about right so essentially it
was a it's a it's a multi-core chip with
a shared memory and then essentially
what happens is this call one you know
there is an instruction which tries to
store value a into memory location one
and you know since you know that's sort
of shared between the two caches what
you try to do is that you try to
invalidate the other entry in the other
cache of core in right now because of
the bug what happened is that the
invalidation signal gets dropped right
so you know core n still has a valid you
know value of memory location 1 but at
some point in time core n tries to you
know perform some operations using
memory location 1 and then you know it
did locks the key point over here is the
distance the time distance is very long
number one and even more importantly you
know when core in deadlocks actually the
bug was happening when cold one was
actually trying to create the you know
was trying to do the operation so it's
almost impossible to go back and tell
you know where in the world this problem
was coming from and this is sort of is
the simplest situation you know that you
can think about the real situations are
much more difficult than this and and
the investor uses a whole bunch of
techniques in app you know here's a long
list i do not have to read this thing
bottom line is all these techniques that
are out there they have very long error
detection latencies so what do we do how
do we solve this problem and here comes
sort of the high level picture of what
QED or quick error detection does what
it does is the following it takes
existing tests that are called I call
them original tests okay like for
example your games your applications or
people even run you know sir all sorts
of you know up you know random
instructions and so on and so forth and
we pass them through a tool which is
called a key
BD transformation to okay and you know
what are these qet transformations
they're like some you know mathematical
transformations i will give you some
examples to give you give you an
intuition very soon and what comes out
of this cutie transformations are a
whole bunch of tests that we call QED
family tests ok now this committee
family tests have some very interesting
properties for example you will be able
to prove that the error detection
latency will be guaranteed very short
for example and as i said earlier
because the error detection latency will
be a very short the coverage will
improve but even more interestingly you
can do this QED transformations
completely in software which means that
of course you don't trust me I'm making
all these clamps standing here right but
you can actually try this on your chip
today and you know you will be able to
see the benefits of this QED
transformations now if you're a little
bit bored and if you give me 0.01
percent of your silicon area then I can
actually do this QED transformations
even better but I know that you won't
trust me on day one and you will just
want the software version of the QED
rather than this hardware-assisted QED
ok so what does this QED do so you know
up what it does is the following
remember I take existing tests and I
sort of you know block down the existing
tests into snippets what a snippets just
a bunch of lines of code for example
right and then you know you have some
kind of an error detection latency
target it doesn't really matter you know
you do not you know like you mean have
to worry about those you have some
intrusiveness constraints for example
you know one of the companies that we
were working with they said boy you are
changing our tests make sure that do
this kind of in a part of the test we
are writing some very specific values
into the memory bus and you better not
touch that focus sir we are not going to
touch that right you know we can respect
all this constraints and what comes out
of these you know QED transformations is
what I call tma which means too many
acronyms right which means that you
don't really have to read through all
these acronyms but you should focus on
is the following you still see that the
snippets are still existing right
snippet one you see a snippet one
snippet 2 and so on and so forth
and I have added a whole bunch of other
stuff that's shown in blue and you don't
have to worry about what those things
are we will talk about it but the
property that will be satisfied is the
following so let's say that snippet one
was you know triggering a bug for
example I would know that by the
beginning of snippet too with all this
blue stuff that I just added I will be
detecting the error that is caused by
the bug so since I know what I am going
to put in in this you know this blue
stuff since I am controlling that I can
control the error detection latency that
sort of is the key idea now the question
is you know what is what are all this
blue stuff that I add I will give you
some kind of you know trivial examples
to motivate you you should not try that
at home but that will give you a sense
for what I am trying to do but before
getting there up so let me you know so
this is a you know big SOC for example
and as I said that associates contain a
whole bunch of components it has
processor cores it has uncle components
like you know cache controllers memory
controllers and so on and it has
accelerators for example so depending on
what part of the associate targeting and
essentially we target the entire associ
there are different kinds of QED
transformations for different parts of
the SOC and I of course i won't have
time to go through all these you know
transformations in this talk but to give
you a sense for these transformations I
will focus on two transformations one
targeting the processor core which is
called an EDD IV transformation and
later on I will show you a
transformation called the PLC
transformation that targets are this
uncle components for example but let's
look at what EDD IV transformation is
and EDD I essentially stands for error
detection by duplicated instructions and
you know you sort of get the idea of
where I'm going I guess so up so up to
give you a motivation for this ed div
transformation so let's take a
validation program as i said i will show
you some pretty trivial examples just to
get you a sense for things you know if
you just try this at home without using
this QED stuff you know it won't exactly
work because there will be you know some
issues
but let's take this transformation right
you know so let's take a bunch of cord
you know and I just picked a bunch of
instructions and if you look at the
trace of the instructions you know you
have a bunch of you know r1 equals to r
1 plus 5 and so on and so forth if a bug
gets triggered somewhere you see that
you know there is a very long error
detection latency before you know that
there is a problem for example right so
what I will do now is the following so I
will actually divide up the registered
space of my processor into two halves
now if you could not do that for some
reason that's perfectly fine there
alternative ways to achieving what I am
talking about but just for the simplest
case let's say that you know i have
registers r1 r2 and r3 and the other
spaces are 16 or 18 and are 19 and what
i have done is that i have identically
initialized this in our 12 hour 16 r 2
to r 18 or 32 hour 19 right and then
when i run this r1 equals to r 1 plus 5
i also run our 16 equals to r 16 plus 5
which mean and then you know when i run
our tickets to our 2-1 Iran are 18
equals to r 18 minus r 16 and so on and
so forth essentially by doing that what
i am doing is on the same hardware i am
creating these two intertwined you know
execution sequences which guarantee that
at certain points in time they should
have consistent results and there's
chicks that are shown in blue over there
whether r1 is equal to r 16 and articles
you are 18 they are making this chicks
very frequently okay so I have instead
of that one test that was running before
I have these two intertwined executions
of the same tests that are running and
very frequently I'm checking that little
those two executions are consistent with
respect to each other or not right I
remember with parity up it comes from
their notion of you know Martin as you
know that I work on fault tolerant
computing and software you know
implemented hardware fault tolerant
computing and so on it comes from there
but why does it work in this space I
will come to that little bit later but
yeah the ideas are coming from that
domain basic
right so what's really going on over
here is that let's say that the bug up
was triggered by r1 equals to r 1 plus 5
you know then you know r1 equals to r 16
you know that would you know catch the
error for example right if r 62 equals
to r 16 plus 5 did not exercise the bug
in exactly the same way everybody agrees
with that makes sense okay good so at
least you know you have some initial
motion that we might be able to catch
this bug very quickly right because I
have such fine grained chicks of this
intertwined executions and I'm going to
come to that okay yeah so that's why i
said that you know don't try this you
know this trivial examples at home lock
stock and barrel because you have to be
very careful about certain things so so
that's the example of you know my error
detection latency was very short right
now let me tell you that my coverage
will improve you know very significantly
why so again let's take a test and when
r 1 equals to r 1 plus 1 was running you
know the two got changed to a three but
then what happened was you know at some
point in the execution of the program
that our 1 got a value 0 and guess what
a whole bunch of people in that in the
domain of verification we'll talk about
what are called assertions for example
right that's a big buzzword right and
let's just somebody had an assertion
which is so check r1 equals to 0 da you
know of course r1 equals to 0 and you
know that would be check and everything
would be fine essentially what happened
was the error that was created by that
bug got masked right now let's take our
previous example that we were talking
about before right so when you around r1
equals to r 1 plus 1 and then our 18
equals to r 18 plus 1 and you do the
check you detect the bug although the
bug would be masked later on and as a
result with no PVD you would have a bog
escape but with QED you will have a very
quick detection of the bug now I'm
absolutely sure all of you are thinking
that G now this guy is just making all
these claims what happens when r 1
equals to r 1 plus 1 and r 18 equals to
r 18 plus 1 get affected in I exactly
you know that same way then I would not
be able to detect the bug and the here
comes fault tolerance so in this world
there are two kinds of bugs the easy
bugs and difficult bugs the easy bugs
are easy why are the easy because every
time you run the test the bug is going
to make the system fail in exactly the
same way this would be you know a lot of
people would call this bore bugs
basically right and if you have a bug
that has that kind of reproducibility
you just need to do a very simple binary
search and you will be exactly be able
to tell in logarithmic number of steps
where the bug is and why is it failing
versus as I said the badness of the most
difficult bugs are is is that they're
like Heisenberg's which means you know
up they are not reproducible now what we
are doing over here is that we are
turning that lemon into a lemonade why
because now think about since you have
the same hardware that's running these
intertwined executions when that I are
you know when that you know duplicated
instruction is running the state of the
system is very different the contents of
all this other flip-flops that are you
know creating the state of the system or
the electrical state of the system is
very different as this gentleman was
saying that the timing is very different
and the result and as a result this
Heisenberg's what they do is that they
create this notion that you do not have
the exact same erroneous behavior that
are affecting these two instructions so
at a high level you can think of it this
way that although the bug is happening
because there was a logic problem or
there was an electrical problem or there
was a farm where problem or even there
was a software problem the way that
difficult Heisenberg behaves in a system
level it looks like as if there was a
cosmic ray heat that came and you know
like created a little error somewhere
and as a result this difficult bugs are
automatically detected because of the
timing diversity of when you know these
bugs are exercised in what way but if
you are not happy with that answer
actually there are a very focused ways
of creating diversity between these
various executions that are intertwined
for example over here you can see that
when i run the r1 equal to a plus B you
run our 18 equals 25 times a prime plus
5 times B Prime and
you a check at a different space so what
would happen is that if a bug affects if
both of these executions the net effect
is not going to be identical and you
will be able to detect the bug and there
is a whole bunch of literature on how to
create this diversity up you know
somebody asked us this question right
you know for the Intel floating-point
bug you know that happened even before i
came to grad school you know would you
find that bag and this diversity would
be a perfect way actually to find that
bug okay so that was like you know one
of the examples targeting processor
cores what do we do for the uncle
components for example the PLC
transformation that I promised to show
you essentially what i just said is that
all these intertwined executions that i
was talking about that would be very
good at finding bugs inside the
processor course but if you look at two
days I sources a very significant chunk
of the assessee actually the majority of
the associate side the processor course
and that's where a lot of bugs happen
because people you know do not have as
much time to integrate all these various
components and make sure that everything
is actually working right so as a result
this uncle components are extremely
important and they are very prone to
very difficult bugs so we will be using
this another transformation called the
PLC transformation to address bugs in
those parts of the SOC so how does the
PLC transformation works well before
getting there so you know I have a
design with many course as shown over
here you know and then you know these
were the original tests the first thing
that I would do is that using that ed
div transformation i transformed that
you know the test that now would now be
running on this individual processor
course and then I will be adding this
other checks are the transformations on
top of that this would be called the PLC
transformations or proactive load and
check transformations what do they do
essentially just like what we talked
about in DD div which was like sort of
splitting the register space and kind of
identical initializing them and making
sure that the intertwined executions are
sort of you know our self consistent now
i will be doing something similar for
the memory space which means that this
proactive loaded
make transformations every so often from
all the threads that are running on all
this processor course they will be
looking at some part of the memory space
and they will make sure that the memory
contents are consistent with respect to
each other and that's how I have
implicitly covered the entire SOC
because if some of this uncle components
would create trouble with respect to
bugs what would happen is that
ultimately some memory location will be
messed up and by doing this proactive
load and check transformations very
frequently I will be reducing the error
detection latency and improving the
coverage with respect to you know those
bugs as well so that's good so you know
hopefully now you sort of see the bigger
picture that you know you deal with bugs
inside the processor cores you deal with
bugs outside the processor cores now
this gentleman has this fantastic
question which is the following right he
said timing but let's take a step back
what's really going on is I have some
tests that was finding bugs and I have
transformed those tests into new tests
and you know to find more bulbs and
finding more bugs more quickly but could
you have really intrusiveness which
means the fact that you are transforming
an existing test into a new test can
that end up in a situation that you
might not find the bug in the first
place because something got skewed up in
a bad way right that sort of you know
where you are coming from probably and
what does the bug coverage impact of
that would be so the way we deal with it
so we have two ways to deal with it one
is a software way to deal with it and
i'm going to show you and that's where
this notion of QED family tests come but
then there is actually a hardware way
which is that if you just give me 0.01
percent of the area then i can actually
play a tiny little bit twix and i can
almost get rid of this notion of you
know that i have to change the tests in
software a lot of these checks will be
happening out of that hardware the 0.01
percent area of the hardware and a lot
of this intrusiveness will be gone but
of course you are not going to give me
this edition additional silicon area so
it's not worth talking about it at least
in this present
so I will tell you how I do it in
software only so what I essentially do
is there is a trade-off between this
error detection latency and
intrusiveness right what is the
trade-off well of course my if my error
detection latency is very long which
means i don't even modify my test then i
would not have any intrusiveness versus
if i go and you know sneak in these
additional instructions that i was
showing you before every for each
instruction right there then it would be
really intrusive so essentially I have
to find a balance between error
detection latency and this inclusiveness
so what we do is that as you can see
over here that we actually change the
snippets so what we do is that we window
it we say well you know four from each
test you create a family of tests and in
each family of each each member of that
family you know you have a certain
window up where you actually go and do
the transformation or to be precise all
the instructions within that window are
not affected and then only you add your
whatever additional instructions you are
adding right so now you have this window
over here you have a window over here
and instructions inside the window are
not affected you know like for one
member in the family and now what you
can do is that you can slide that window
and as a result you can show that at
least there will be one member in your
family where if a bug got triggered by
that sequence of instructions that will
be held as it was in the original test
and as a result the bug would be found
by at least one test in the new family
test and that's how we get around this
whole issue about you know inclusiveness
and you know our hardware results show
that that is extremely effective in
actually finding bugs okay good so I
talk a lot at this point what I'm going
to show you is I'm going to show you
some results and then I'm going to hand
it over to Clark who will get into this
symbolic version of this QED to show
that how you can use it for sort of
formal verification of very large
associés you know we are going to show
you results for an associate with half a
billion transistors billion with a be
but before that let me show you that QED
very effective for electrical bugs so I
was very fortunate that my friends at
Intel they actually brought in an actual
core i7 hardware into our lab okay and
what you can see over here this blue
thing that you can see is actually a
debug board it's a custom debug board
essentially through this port you can
change the voltage and the frequency of
that processor at a very fine level so
that's a way to create electrical bugs
right and then the challenge was if you
ran the original tests what would be the
error detection latency and coverage and
if you ran this new QED tests what would
be the other detection latency and
coverage and as you can see that with
this QED you get six orders of magnitude
improvement in error detection latency a
million times real Hardware result so
the original tests had error detection
latencies of 1 to 10 billion clock
cycles versus we have very short error
detection latencies and it's no wonder
that we also detect lot more errors that
the original test would not detect
because we are detecting everything so
quickly now one question you might ask
is that hey still you got zero to ten
thousand over here like why is it so why
isn't it in a shorter than 10,000 well
guess what in a since this was one of
the first experiments that we were doing
I did not want my student to fiddle
around with the x86 binary or the x86
assembly we said that we will be doing
this QED at a sea level because this QED
technique can be applicable either at
the sea level assembly level binary
level you name it we can do it you know
and we have done it you know for many
chips but so so if you if you instrument
this thing at the sea level then there
would be some sea level library routines
that we stuck in right now if the error
got triggered when that library routine
was running you have to get out of that
library routine for QED to detect it and
that sort of ended up having you know
like very few cases with five thousand
and six thousand cycles of error
detection latency as you can see the
overwhelming majority was just a few
hundred cycles of error detection
latency for this very complex chip you
know up for you know just using software
only techniques the other question we
were asked at that point is that all
these errors that we were detecting
right
had you know 4x more errors that we
detected do those things correspond to
actually unique coverage improvement and
the only way to demonstrate that would
be through a smooth lot for those of you
that do not know what a schmoo plot is
is essentially a frequency versus
voltage plot so if you reduce a voltage
a lot this chip should not work right
because at a very high frequency right
so the Reds are bad the greens means
things have passed but if you look at
this particular voltage frequency point
of course I cannot tell you what that
numbers are up you know what you will
see is that if you ran the original test
it would be green but if you run the QED
test it would detect error which means
that it's a unique detection and by the
way it since QED programs are absolutely
valid programs it's not like bringing
you're bringing the processor to some
illegal state and you are detecting
something illegal basically you are
actually it's a real detection it's a
true cover this improvement well what is
the only hardware you know like no you
know like the my Intel friends also
brought in what Intel would call a
single chip cloud computer I think it
was a 48 core chip you don't have to
read through everything on the slide
bottom line is the results are exactly
similar as i was showing before does
this mean that this technique works only
for electrical bugs no you know we it
also works for logic bugs and i'm going
to show you some examples of that so
here was a hardware that you know we
were challenged in it's an associate
from freescale and what happened over
here is that i was telling you right
they were running it for a 15 billion
clock cycles after 15 seconds of
operation what essentially happened
after 10 seconds of operation this was
1.5 gigahertz this chip would hang this
ship would hang but there would not be
any observable failure so how would you
go and tell we know what is the bug it
took them several months to figure out
you know where the bug was so we were
challenged you know what we did simply
was we took their original test whatever
it was running and it was in binary so
we did not even know what the test was
doing okay you just passed it through
this QED you know trick that I just
showed you and it took us a few seconds
to
happy tell that the sequence of eight
instructions that was actually causing
the problem and you have to find the
problem so 8 plus 1 is 9 so as you can
see that with nine within nine cycles we
could exactly tell where the bug is from
that 15 billion and in a few seconds
compared to several months okay so it
works for logic bugs whatever dollar
logic bugs well I was very fortunate
that all these companies that are shown
over here they gave me access to their
actual bog databases where we found a
lots of very difficult bugs and one
thing that we did is that we abstracted
this bugs into something what I call bug
benchmark so that the community the
academic community can actually use this
bug benchmarks to validate their
verification techniques the lack of that
you are caught in a rot the other line
is again over and over again you will
see that if you run existing ways of
doing things you have very long error
detection latencies with QED you very
significantly improve error detection
latencies and you improve coverage this
was an industrial cash by a company you
can see they were very proud of their
tests you can see the 10 billion cycles
of error detection latencies versus QED
finds it very quickly and it finds
unique bugs that they couldn't have
found and it goes over and over and on
and on and on you know like power
management bugs you name it up in a farm
where Boggs same story i am not going to
go through the details is skewed useful
for hardware accelerators because aren't
we using software and if you had a
hardware accelerator which is sort of
you know you know shielded from the
software how would you you know do QED
on that i'm not going to go through the
details there is a paper that you know
talks about this thing the only point
that i would like to mention is how do
people design accelerators they take a
sea level design or c++ design or domain
specific language design and bypass it
through high level synthesis to create
hardware accelerators so when we did
this work my challenge to the students
was well then we should find bugs in the
C code right because that those are the
real bugs and guess what we found unique
bugs in the sea level design in the C
code corresponding to
designs that people didn't know about
and whoever maintains the sea level
designs they confirm with us that those
were real bugs that were not found so as
I said that you can find bugs in
software but we didn't do a very
extensive study with you know commercial
software that's why I did not make the
claim earlier but we have some Inklings
that it might work for software too so
now the question you know with the
symbolic qet technique that you know
Clark is going to talk about that's
where that comes in so the question
really is at this point that now that we
have reduced the error detection
latencies and you know we have improved
coverage how do we really go from you
know months to overnight automatically
which means that now once i have
detected the bug very quickly i should
be able to localize the bug
automatically without the designer
intervention and what does localization
mean it means that i should be able to
tell where in the big you know chip a
tiny piece of hardware where the bug
resides and what is the nature of the
bug which means that some kind of a very
short trace that would expose the bug
right if it was a for example the logic
bug or something and here is what you
know Clark is going to show so with the
symbolic qvt technique he's going to
show results as I said on a half a
billion transistors SOC so traditionally
it would take weeks or months but a
symbolic QED will be able to do this job
within 20 minutes to five hours
depending on the size of the design
blocks and so on traditionally it's
manual symbolic QED will do it
automatically and finally traditionally
you would have this really long bug
dresses that you have to look at to find
out where exactly the bug is what's
causing the bath versus symbolic QED
will give you very short tresses very
succinct traces to nail down the bug I
would stop at this point to take any
questions and then hand it over to Clark
yes so bit earlier he mentioned that
you're mostly just when we talk about
software implementations of QED but then
you are littered to there being some
part where yes there is a mother
which I did not talk about but I if you
are interested send me an e-mail I'll be
very glad to sit down with you and chat
about it the point is the hardware
overhead of adding that stuff is
extremely small and actually you can
reuse some of the for example memory
built-in self-test controllers that you
already have inside your cheap you can
use some of that to do the hardware
version second question I when you were
just talking about high level synthesis
based accelerators being saying like
what type of accelerators so a whole
bunch of accelerators for example signal
processing accelerators you know and I
think some cryptographic stuff most
accelerators that people would use yeah
and what we used is like a whole bunch
of benchmarks that you know people have
academic community uses you gotta push
yes you're getting like faster detection
by adding these sequences in
electricians have you compared it to
order the cases they're already
industrial cases already include things
like Delta debugging my algorithms like
test case reduction yes so you know we
looked at a whole bunch of industrial
examples and all of them have very long
error detection latencies that's the
trouble you know because most of the for
example you know that simplest example
of this Delta kind of stuff would be
like to you know put in a lot of
assertions for example between various
points or to have checkpointing for
example to go back to a state you know
like and so on and so forth and and and
all of them have long interdiction
latencies go ahead yes it's me silly
yeah soft robot so much you do is
instead like adding more check once or
something you would just say no it
doesn't even cut the program in binary
search basically and those are very good
at finding borebots that reproduce
themselves very well but when you have a
Heisenberg like a like you know like
that those are the most difficult bugs
basically it's very hard because next
time you will be running those various
binary chunks basically the effects of
the bugs will be gone you're a question
yeah this operation taking here doing
your moving reinforce its together yes
you know so there's as we noted in pre
and post especially
what I've been showing me you would see
that the exact similar ones you can be
used in pre as well sheesh my expertise
is in formal methods and we start
looking at you know this this qet
technique and wondering conformal health
tears or something we can do and so the
first observation of course is that this
everything you've seen so far is still a
testing technique right so we take the
existing test we make them better but if
your original tests can't find the bug
then QED won't find the bug either so
the first idea we had well is can we
make this more exhausted and then I
think a nice observation is that all of
these two soul technique this cutie
technique is based on the observation
that if there's above in an SOC the bug
is observable by the processor core
right because if the if it doesn't
affect the processor core in any way
it's not a bug so there's a way to use
the core as this sort of magic probe
that can probe all of the SOC and that's
a key idea as well okay so the technique
we came up with symbolic quick error
detection has the following properties
so if it is a more exhaustive technique
okay so it's going to find bugs that
even your tests would miss it's going to
do it automatically so it uses an
automatic formal engine and it works
four cores as well as uncor and other
components and then because this is a
formal technique meaning it runs on a
model of the processor not on the
hardware you can use it both pre and
post okay and it makes your engineers
happy all right so we're going to use a
technology called bounded model checking
and just to introduce this to you if
you're not unfamiliar with it the idea
is you have a model a design some piece
of hardware and then you have to have a
property that you want to check a
property that this piece of hardware
should satisfy you put these two things
into a BMC tool let it think and it will
automatically
you back a counter example if one exists
okay now the technology behind mounted
mall checking is based on the explosion
of improvements in boolean
satisfiability and related
satisfiability techniques which are
remarkable and continue to improve very
quickly so so we're leveraging that
breakthrough technology now to to show
you a little bit more in detail how this
works what you you can look at your
design as you know a set of flip-flops
running through some logic back into the
flip-flops what we're going to do is
we're going to take that sequential
design and we're going to unroll it into
an into a combinational circuit that
represents running that circuit for
several cycles now the idea is you would
you would put some constraints on the
initial set of flip-flops that would
represent the state that you want to
start in you would put some constraints
on the inputs that would represent what
kinds of inputs are legal and then you
would put a check on the final set of
flip-flops that would represent the
property that you're trying to look for
and then you turn this whole thing into
a satisfiability problem and the
satisfiability engine looks for some set
of inputs that satisfy the constraints
that you've given that would cause the
property to be violated and if there
exists such a set of inputs it will find
it furthermore the way you do this
typically is you'll unroll it one level
at a time and do the check at each level
so you're guaranteed to find the
shortest the shortest distance from the
initial state that actually violates the
property so that's one of the the key
properties of bounded model checking as
you get these short counter examples
okay now as you might expect there are
pros and cons to using this kind of
technology so one of the most difficult
issues is you have to have this property
where does the property come from you
know and typically the way about a mile
checking is used in industries people
right manual properties or they have
some sort of automatic assertions that
get inserted but a lot of those
assertions are probably junk or most of
them don't catch bugs and just take up
extra space so this is not
this is a typically one big bottle net
the other the other thing the next to
the bounded model checking bound in the
design sighs so for a lot obviously for
larger circuits you can unroll less but
in any case you know there's sort of a
limit to how many cycles you can unroll
before even the even today's fast
engines get bogged down and then of
course the input constraints also need
to be specified and that's that's a
project a problem that's dual to the
property problem what's very nice about
the technique that we have is we in a
very nice way we're able to deal with
all these problems so i'm going to show
you how we deal with the property
problem and basically what we're doing
is we're leveraging the QED to come up
with a universal property which i think
is very exciting the other thing is
because the QED technique is designed to
find bugs fast we end up only having to
unroll a few cycles we also have a
technique for dealing with large
associés and part of the properties of
QED allow us to partition the SOC in
various ways to get around a large
design size and then we have a hardware
module that's only used during testing
you don't have to put on your chip call
the QED module that helps solve the
problem of the input constraints ok so
the first problem I'm going to look at
is the property issue so you don't know
what the bugs you're looking for so that
makes it difficult to write good
properties you would you ideally you
would like to write properties that
cover all possible bugs but this is very
difficult ok so the current state of the
art is that properties are big
bottleneck and then the other challenge
like I mentioned is the size so to
address property one what how on earth
are we going to come up with the
universal property ok so the key idea is
the property that we're going to check
is does there exist any QED test that
could fail ok so we're going to leverage
this idea of the QED test and we're
going to allow it to range over all
possible sequences of instructions
shins so just to remind you what was
said earlier this duplicate and
duplicate and check technique it would
take a sequence of instructions
duplicate them on a on a shadow set of
registers in memory and then compare the
results okay so we can do this
symbolically right so rather than saying
we're going to pick these three you know
the instructions from your test we're
going to say we're going to flip it on
its head and say the bounded model
checker will now pick from the set of
all possible instructions a sequence of
instructions and then we're going to
duplicate that sequence and we're going
to check if the result is is identical
and that whole problem now is symbolic
so it's going to search the space of all
possible sequences and duplicate
sequences okay now we have to be a
little bit careful about the property
that we're checking right so in QED the
property that we check is that the
registers and the shadow registers match
obviously this isn't going to work
unless we are a little bit more careful
about what the sequence looks like right
so you could trivially set the two
registers to different values that's the
legal sequence of instructions and it
wouldn't match so what we have to do is
constrain the input sequence to be what
we call a QED trace meaning that it
consists of a set of instructions
followed by a duplicate set of
instructions and only at that point do
we check the result okay I think I just
said that in order to do that now that
that kind of a constraint is a little
bit difficult to write so we're going to
we're going to utilize a piece of
hardware to do it this QED module so the
idea is we add this little QED module to
our fetch unit and what happens is the
set of instructions that the bounded
model checker chooses then passed
through the module and the module
produces two sequences and this is
actually pretty easy to do all you have
to do is decode the instruction look for
the parts of the instructions that deal
with either registers or memory and just
move those into the shadow registers and
shadow memory when you do the duplicate
okay so you basically have just a little
state machine it's going to run
sequence and then it's going to rerun
the same sequence and the second time
you have the duplicate flag on and it's
just going to make this transformation
okay and we've implemented this and the
module is is not it's not difficult to
implement okay all right so how does
this work now so we have the QED module
attached the processor core it
automatically duplication instructions
and it also knows when it's legal to do
this comparison right basically it's
just you know I'm not going into all the
details but you know you have to be a
little bit careful about things like
when instructions commit and stuff like
this so it tracks all of that and it
knows when both the original and the
duplicate set of instructions are
finished and committed and when it's
legal to compare the results okay now of
course you also have to be careful about
the initial state remember I said part
of setting up a bounded model checking
problem is getting the right initial
state and hear what we have to do is
just ensure that in the initial state
the original and shadow copies of
everything are the same okay now you
could do that symbolically what we found
is it was good enough just to run some
simple simulation get to what we call a
QED consistent state where the the
original and shadow memories and
registers are the same and we just
extract that state and dump it into the
mounted model checker and it turned out
you know in our experiments what we saw
was that it didn't matter too much what
tests we ran or you know at what point
we captured the result just as long as
we had some consistent state it was it
was able to work okay now remember what
suba she said that we have that QED has
this property of guaranteeing quick
detection what this means is that
because because we have this this
property will be able to find a will
usually be able to find a bug if one
exists in a few cycles and this
addresses the issue of you know bounded
model checking gets worse as you unroll
more cycles in fact for the for the
results will show you later we were able
to find all the bugs in something like
less than 10 psychic
so so there was always some QED test of
just a few cycles long that would detect
the bug okay now of course you can
invent pathological examples where this
is not the case but but for real bugs we
believe this is the case okay so what do
we have now so now we have this
Universal property we're going to search
the space of all QED tests we have the
initial state that's just some QED
consistent state and then we have our
model plus the QED module and we're
going to put all that together into the
bounded mall checker okay so that
addresses the first challenge which is
properties which i think is pretty
exciting so for basically if you have a
chip with processor with a core that has
instructions you can apply this
technique and you don't have to write
properties right you can just use the
QED property now what about the second
challenge the design sighs okay so the
idea we have here is to use something
called partial instantiation because in
a multi-core chip what you typically
have is lots of repeated components and
so we don't actually need all of the
components in the soc in order to
exercise the functionality in particular
for example if there's a bug in the
uncor most likely we can find it with a
single core worst case probably two
cores and some combination of
instructions and those two cores will
exercise the bug on the other hand if we
have a bug in the core we just need a
core we don't need any of the uncor and
so on so our idea is basically to just
partition this up in a bunch of
different ways you know pick a partition
like this pick another partition looks
like this another one looks like this
and we're just going to run all of these
different partitions in parallel and
whichever one pops out with a bug first
great we'll take it furthermore what
this allows you to do is to localize
with respect to the actual location the
module in the design so for example if
we get to results with a bug trace
then we can look at the two and say AHA
this one doesn't need that extra cash
mate we can find it with just a single
cash mate ok so now why does this work
basically there's a key idea here which
is this technique of using QED tests as
a property gives you a very nice
compositional property right so suppose
you are just writing assertions and you
want to check something about cache
coherency you might have a property that
says something like if core one writes a
particular line in the cache and core
two reads the line then the line is in
the shared state ok so this is a great
property it'll catch that bug but it's
not compositional with respect to
removing parts of the design so if i
remove core two now what does this
property become that doesn't make sense
however the QED checks are compositional
because as long as you keep at least one
core you can run instructions on that
core and you can configure your your
system to have as many caches or memory
banks and basically you just have to
have some legal configuration and these
things are designed to be plugged
together in various ways so just you
just have to have various legal
configurations and all of them should
work ok so the cute the property of QED
consistency or checking the QED test
works for all of these configurations so
it is compositional all right so to
summarize we have our universal property
we have partial instances with the QED
modules and we put all this together in
our bounded model checker tool and and
you can run this you know and within a
few hours you do get these results ok so
i'm going to show you one example and
i'll talk about results so what does it
look like for for very specific example
suppose that we have a bug which at
which manifests as follows
after you load from consecutive cache
lines the next load is corrupted alright
so what we would do is we would set the
prop the property so we don't even know
what this bug is right we're just going
to generally check whether there's any
QED test that does something strange so
using this particular example symbolic
you ed can find a bug trace with four
instructions to original and to
duplicate instructions and what happens
is basically it says we're going to load
our one from a particular memory address
then load our two and notice that we're
loading our two from a consecutive cache
line ok so the bug gets triggered now
these two instructions pass through the
QED module and and for the first two
instructions it's just a no op right
it's just identity function now we get
to the end of the sequence and we send a
restart signal so the pc gets set back
to the address of the first instruction
and we actually load those two
instructions again but now the QED
module is in the duplicate mode and it's
going to transform them by changing the
register and the memory to use the
duplicate address now what's going to
happen is the load into our 17 is going
to get corrupted that's the that's the
bug is that the next load after loads
from consecutive cache lines is
corrupted so our 17 is not going to
match our one and so when we get to the
final state our QED our BMC property
that the registers in the shadows match
will be violated ok all right so just so
to review these are this is what we get
and let's look at some results ok so we
did a case study using the open spark t2
this is a very large chip it's got half
a billion transistors and we inserted 92
difficult logic bugs that the bugs were
taken from various bugs in the database
where we had all kinds of different
activation criteria
mine's a different manifestations they
included bugs in the core bugs in the
uncor and power management bugs okay and
the first the first point to make is
that any one of these bugs would be
extremely difficult to localize running
the bounded mall checking was automatic
so once we'd set up the environment is
the same environment for all the bugs it
takes anywhere from 20 minutes to seven
hours okay and it found all of them and
this gives you a little bit of a this
drills down a little bit showing you the
time so for the processor core bugs it
found them you quite quickly and one and
the reason is you only need to run bound
and while checking on a single core to
find these bugs right so you you have a
smaller design and you can find them
quickly for the uncor bugs it took a
little bit longer but still it was still
tractable and power management bugs find
those too okay and just another point
here we ran we basically ran symbolic
QED with an initial state obtained by
running an fft QED test and i'll show
you also some comparisons of i think
i'll show you if not i'll tell you the
comparison of what happens if you run
QED versus symbolic QED ok now here's
where the real magic happens is the
reduction in the bug trace okay so if
you run uh I'm not sure I actually have
the results with comparing with QT I
don't ok so let me just tell you so if
you what we found is if you run the
original test like fft or something else
and just do end result checks basically
what you get is you know millions of
clock cycles and we found half of the
bugs okay if you run if you now take the
f of t test use the QED transforms on it
you find all the bugs that's great the
error reduction the error latency is
reduced to something on the order of a
hundred to a thousand
clock cycles you do the same now if you
take the same buggy design and run it
through symbolic you Ed it spits out a
trace that is something like five
instructions okay so even if you got
that 10,000 cycle trace from QED it
still it would take a while to debug
that if you if you're given a trace of
five instructions I mean that's going to
take you a few minutes right you can you
can use a waveform viewer you can like
trace through exactly what's going on
and and that really gives you what you
need to find these things quickly okay
right so so yeah this is comparing
against the original end result checks
just in more detail so like I said the
original test found only half the bugs
symbolic UT finds all the bugs the
number of cycles is something like you
know on the order of 1 to 10 million and
the number of cycles for symbolic you
ities on the order of 10 to 30 all right
so happy engineers all right so that's
that's just to summarize then what we
have with with QED and symbolic QED is a
set of techniques for finding bugs both
pre and post silicon drastically
improving the error detection latency
giving you shorter error traces that you
can debug quickly and this works for for
all kinds of bugs core encore etc the
QED technique of course works for
electrical bugs post silicon symbolic
QED technique that I presented today is
only for logic bugs but we have work in
progress for how you might adapt that to
even help find the electrical bugs post
silicon all right and I'll stop there
and take any questions
I'm surprised you didn't say that we
inserted 92 bucks and 518 because what
are the odds that there's not seen other
bugs in the hot part that is right so we
actually were hoping to find some
unknown bug and open spark we ran
symbolic QED up to a window I think of
like 50 cycles now we didn't we didn't
find any so I guess open spark is a
pretty thoroughly debug design you know
it could be that there are still bugs in
there and and maybe if we we didn't use
any diversity here right so you could do
symbolic you ed with diversity by having
the QED module insert diversity as it
transforms so yeah there are some other
things you know this is sort of a first
proof of concept but yeah I suspect that
with a less vetted design we would find
something yeah
so surely there are any number of us
well that it designs in the world from
people that might welcome your help
finding motors they don't already know
about yeah we've been talking to a
number of Industry people who are
interested in this yeah tortured those
pokey designs may have never survived
right only did the graveyard yeah so 11
tests we did want to try that we didn't
was maybe going back you know taking
like revision histories and looking at
old buggy designs but I think the bugs
there probably are are less difficult to
find the ones we inserted so I think we
find them yeah I remember way about
talking to both until the Sun but design
tools and Gaver the liver generally you
should turn the camera on the fin Sons
songs design up to they found fewer
errors may be that they were decides are
so good at the hardware whatever
checking they did afterwards they didn't
find too many bars on because each
outfit find a lot so they're very happy
those two yeah gives you a few hints but
like super don't share who goes these
these days nobody's nobody's not tiny
bugs right because the complexity is
just pushing available yeah well they
have those young designers they don't
have his old great reflection should
have asked me um the Martin sort of
mentioned at the the old lockstep or
redundant computation stuff with a
little diversity was that sort of proto
QED in the sense that what I'm love
their different you just don't know why
so was it possible they were detecting
bugs and just writing it off with
something else because you weren't doing
you put the computation frequent checks
deep inside Margaret back when they I
believe the frame praise when Intel was
not bigger than IBM and I be able to say
mainframe quality processors as opposed
to those toys yeah
I think it's fair to say there a number
of inspirations for QED and some things
that are similar i think what's really
been done here is to sort of systematize
it and and you know love us and was
testing i'm saying they were just
finding finding discrepancies run it off
to something else and yeah never
realized what there was a bug and
instead of called called a very
temporary fault akshay attic and even
more gray hair cut my flame i asked him
about it I could that's how it started
and he designed the floating point unit
for the IMC 6071 not meaningful but I
going look 91 91 sorry oh and you
basically know about numerical analysis
so yeah now to brake tests basically do
which are the digital analogue if you
weigh show they get your version of
parody that's the reason why I mentioned
parody before the miniature the findings
you can do high order parity the highest
story is essentially majority okay so
you can have a whole complete spectrum
yeah I mean there are a lot of other
great techniques and in fact until you
has some very good formal people and
they do they do some things actually
with higher order theorem proving where
they where they take in particularly for
their floating point stuff they're
actually able to you know come up with
an algebraic model prove that against
some an intermediate model and then
prove that against the actual rtl they
have you know I some of that work is
really good i'll agree it's obviously in
the algebraic content and that's why did
mention miami for but they are digital
equivalent she said satisfiability what
does it really mean oh well it doesn't
make one more bad jokes oh but your QED
you know there's also another meaning of
QED what am I like two dynamics and
quantum computing if you wish I have
something more reason than that that's
cool pencil networks essentially they
use singular value decomposition to get
close and that there's a boolean
equivalent to that
because what he satisfiability it's such
a question I can it being boarded
because he is the logic any put that out
but would be invertible that's obvious
now obviously most our circuits or not
although they typically have a las told
me about the number of typically put
same logic partisan square root of
number of outputs up having more outputs
it's much more likely to make it
invertible at that point you can
basically use is in portability
properties then you can do it much more
systematically even for the logic the
fun part is that's what's happening
implicitly in quantum computing
executive-level back this table number
alpha I don't art and via the
satisfiability engines that we're using
here are you know they're quite at this
kid so we used the mentor graphics
engine and the reason we use that is
because I was actually involved in
developing that inch and a long time ago
and it was a part of 0 and design
automation my advisor was David Diehl
would we work together on that but they
have higher you know I know that team
and they have you know really good
people who are up on the very latest
satisfiability techniques so it's
actually you know that in and of itself
just the satisfiability engine is quite
a marvel of technology so we're trying
to leverage that as much as possible
except most of these people don't know
anything about physics so they have a
learned that the QED tricks to go around
in there basically QED but inherently as
in portable operators right and that can
be mapped back and ordinary logic I'm
thinking that one of the ways the
military is criticized is they say the
generals are constantly fighting the
previous war you know after ad we can't
agree after you've gone through
something and you know that a
possibility exists you get really good
at rediscovering that possibility to
what extent are you might your system be
especially well suited
finding the sorts of bugs you yourself
can already envision it as opposed to
the sorts of bugs that nobody will see
coming until lip and found and then they
discover that your tools fail to take
that into account so I actually would be
quite interested in exploring that
question because what so I what I like
about this technique is it's very
general right it will catch it will
basically tell you if there is any QED
test that could fail so the question is
what are the kinds of bugs that cannot
be caught by acuity test of some
reasonable size right so it could fail
in a couple of ways one is that for some
reason you know this this duplicate and
duplicate in check with diversity still
misses it right and what is the class of
bugs that that might miss I I think
that's an excellent research question
and then the other thing is what are the
classes of bugs that are only found
where the minimum QED test is really
really long right that would be another
class of bugs that we would have
difficulty finding so you know what I
would love to do is go partner with a
real design team and shake out a bunch
of bugs first of all I think this is a
very general technique I think it's
going to shake out a lot of bugs and
once you once you're able to run this up
to like unrolls of a hundred and you
don't find any bugs you know I'm would
be pretty happy but then I'd be really
interested in knowing what came out
after that right what are we missing and
then how could you improve this
technique and I think sort of a you know
in the trenches approach would be a good
way to to try understand that problem
it's a quick comment of that my period
and I own a fairly example it's the
simples I can imagine it's not though
striking also not the most insightful
whatever but they are all that
equivalents I said feel the other
extremely tight flames or isn't it but
again you that's very limited in
timonium difficult digital systems these
days people cannot imagine any maps that
have anything to do with that so the
typical approaches don't really help you
right but they're they're out there
definitely cool well
you